be telling us something clear about
quantum garbled circuits well well um
okay and let's do it
can you guys see my screen yep that's
all right
uh hi everyone um yeah it's uh it's
really great uh to be in this well
remotely uh
sadly uh in the workshop and i have to
say i'm a bit disappointed that i'm the
only one who abided by the dress code
i thought we were all going to you know
wear the shirts uh
but i guess it's just me um yeah so i'm
going to tell you a little bit about
um about quantum garbled circuits and
this is joint work with henry ewan
uh so let me start by um
explaining a notion called randomizing
coding and i'm going to tell you how it
relates to garbled circuits
so um i'm going to start in the
classical setting so let's
let's take an example which is just the
parity function so a parody of n bits is
just an xor
of these of these n bits and let's think
about the way that we
compute this function so usually we're
going to do it using a tree so this is n
equals 4 but it easily extends
so i'm just going to take sort of a
binary xor tree and i'm going to be able
to compute my
my um parity function uh and this
naturally has uh logarithmic depth well
it has to because the output depends on
all inputs
um and what i want to describe to you
is an encoding of this function so i'm
going to use this
triangle notation in order to in order
to note in encoding
so by encoding a mean i'm going to show
you a different function which i claim
captures the properties of this parity
function
in a way that i will describe in a
minute so this function is going to be
quite different from parity
uh in particular it's going to have
multiple output bits so it's not going
to be just a single bit function like
parity
and it's going to have more than four
well more than n uh
input bits so it's not going to have the
same number of input bits it's not going
to have the same number of output bits
and yet i'm going to claim that it's an
encoding of the parity function in an
interesting way
so let's see how we define the encoding
for this particular function
so what i'm going to do is i'm going to
take a random bit i'm going to sample a
random bit
for each wire of this xor tree
and now i'm going to consider the
following function so
it takes the original input and then for
each
node of this xor tree it computes the
xor
of all the variables that are adjacent
to this node
so we're going to have for the input
nodes we're going to have you know the
x1 x or x r1
and so forth and then for these
intermediate nodes well we're going to
have again the xor of all the r's that
are adjacent
to each one of these nodes and in the
end we're going to have this uh
r7 which is for this sort of output node
and this is going to be my function so
this is a function
that takes well it takes x1 to x4 and in
addition it takes r1 to r7 so additional
inputs
and it also has eight output bits so it
outputs all of these
uh um individual bits um so
it's sort of very different from the
original function and another important
property that we want to notice
is that um this this the depth of this
function
is going to be independent of n so it's
actually going to have
depth 2 regardless of the original
number of inputs
with the number of input bits that i had
for my parrot
so why do i claim that this function
actually encodes uh
the um the original parity function well
the what i'm going to show is that from
the output of this function we can
actually generate
the output of the parity function on the
respective inputs and
also something along the lines of the
opposite also holds
so let's start with a correctness
property so i argue that given the
output
of the encoding function so all of these
eight bits i can compute the original
parity
and this is easy to verify you just xor
all these eight bits
and you're going to get the original
parity of the original four bits
so uh we have correctness here and
correctness holds perfectly
regardless of what the bits are which
bits are i i chose
i'm going to get the original parity
that i wanted
the other property is privacy or
simulation
and here i want to argue that this new
function f hat does not compute much
more
than or does not compute anything more
than the original parity function
so when i gave you this output i
actually didn't tell you anything
about x1 up to x4 except for their
parity
and this is formalized using the
simulation paradigm which is very common
in cryptography
and where we say well if i give you the
output just the the
xor of x1 up to x4 then i can sample
from the distribution
of outputs of f hat that corresponds to
these x1 up to x4 so notice that i don't
know anything about x1 up to
up to x4 except for the xor for their
xor for the output of
f and yet i manage to sample from the
output of f hat
so given an output of f i can
sample from the output space of f hat so
in this case it's also not hard to see
that this holds
actually sort of just take these eight
bits to be random
subject to uh their xor being the the
right value
and this is going to give you a perfect
simulation this is going to be
distributed in the exact same manner as
uh the original uh the original effect
so
um this is a perfect uh simulation but
you can also think about statistical
simulation where
you sample from distribution that's
statistically close or even from
distribution that's computationally
indistinguishable
from the real distribution of f hat
okay good so i maybe explained you know
why i have this other function which
i claim captures the properties of f
but why would you want to do this why
would you want to take a function and
encode it um by a different function
well i mean this only makes sense if
this encoding
has favorable properties compared to the
original function
so every function is also an encoding of
itself trivially
but i want to come up with encodings
that have uh properties that i can use
so in crypto in cryptography this notion
of encoding found
multiple uses which again um uses the
fact hinges on the fact that
f-hat captures the properties of f but
still has very low complexity
in this case it's going to have low low
depth or low locality
but you can think about encodings that
have other computational properties
uh which are favorable um for
for um for various for various tasks
that we want to perform
so for addition for example if you want
to perform secure computation
of arbitrary functions f then we could
instead
perform uh reduce it to the task of
securely computing
randomizing encodings of of the function
that we want to compute
and then we're guaranteed that um sort
of this gives us the functionality that
we need because from
the output of f hats we can recover the
output of f and also we did not
lose anything in terms of privacy
because we did not learn anything
from the output of f hat that we
couldn't have learned from the output of
f
and indeed um low depth complexity comes
very comes in very handy uh when you
design secure computation protocols
but randomized encodings have been used
for delegated computation
for non-black box constructions of
various kinds and even
fairly recently for circuit lower bounds
so this is a very uh a very useful
notion
so we'd like to sort of study it so
let's take another look at what we have
here
and look at some additional interesting
properties of this uh randomizing coding
of the
of the xor of the parity function so
first of all notice that
it has a property that i call
decomposability and this means that in
the
randomized encoding um each bit of the
original
input is actually treated separately so
i can actually compute this randomizing
coding
um even when each input bit is held by a
different party
and just they all have access to this
random string r1 up to r7
and this function can still be computed
uh in this in this way
and this is again uh sort of a useful
property uh
for you know again um it argues for the
simplicity
of the randomized encoding compared to
the original compared to the original
function
so um we have this decomposability
property
so the values that depend on the
original inputs depend only
at most on one original input bit and
then there are some parts that only
depends on the randomness and not on any
of these input bits
so this is this decomposability property
so i've been talking about randomizing
coding
but the title of the paper is garbled
circuit so what is a garbled circuit
well this term is used for um in various
ways in cryptographic literature
so let me not give uh sort of a
definition
but rather say that garbled circuits are
usually regarded as sort of types of
randomized encodings
that are computed they're computable for
a class of circuits
uh class of functions sorry not just for
one function so for example you can
think about the class of all
circuits of a given size so this is sort
of a scheme that allows you to
perform encodings for each uh function
in this class
and in addition usually when you talk
about well doubled circuit
it means that the goblin procedure is
done in a gate by gate manner so
similarly to what you see here
so i sort of do some operation on each
and every gate
you can think about this decomposability
but not with respect to the input but
also with respect to the gates of the
original circuit the circuit that i'm
trying to
uh to encode so this is what i would
call a garbold circuit
uh but i think the most the more
well-defined term would be randomized
encoding
and indeed it turns out that you can do
these garbage circuits or randomizing
coding for
uh general circuit classes um they're
they're
um more there's more than one way of
doing it um
it's it's more complicated than what's
shown here but uh you can think there's
sort of a moral
similarity in in the case that you're
sort of trying to encode
the functionality of each one of the
gates of the circuit using
uh randomness so this is what we can do
classically
um and and we we wanted to try to think
whether you can import this notion to
the quantum setting and what it actually
means
and let me just say that well if you if
you look at this uh
sort of decomposable encoding property
um it gives you the following sort of
strong
application i would say so let's assume
that uh we have two parties and each one
of them only holds a part of the input
and what they want is to allow a third
party to compute a function
on both of these on both of these inputs
but not to learn anything else other
than the output of the function
and using uh randomized encoding you can
do this
with only having shared randomness
between uh between these two parties
so in the quantum setting i think it's
not um
trivially clear how to do this so if you
have a quantum state that is shared
between two parties
and you want to allow a third party to
learn some
function that's computed on the joint
state uh without the two parties
communicating between themselves
um it's not it's not a trivial task to
perform and therefore
this is one reason we thought it would
be interesting to sort of study this
notion in the quantum setting
so the first thing that we do is try to
define randomizing coding in the quantum
setting
and the definition is very similar to
what we saw before so again we want to
encode a function f
using a function f hat and now we're
allowing f to be a general quantum
function so we can have unitary
have measurements tracing out
introducing new registers whatever you
want
so a general sort of quantum circ i mean
circuit
um and we want to encode f using an f
hat
and this f hat takes the original input
which is now it's going to be a quantum
state
it takes some additional randomness like
before and we also allowed to take some
additional
um some additional quantum state some
additional entanglement
and this is actually only needed if we
want to achieve decomposability
otherwise you can just generate this
by yourself f hat can just generate e by
itself uh but for the definition we want
to allow it explicitly
so you take x you take some randomness
and you take some
entanglement and you again
want to generate an output from which
you can
recover you can decode the original
output f of x
and the simulation property again is
that given f of x
you should be able to sample from uh um
the output from the output distribution
of of
f hat and again you can think about
perfect or statistical or computational
notions of simulation
and know that all of this needs to hold
also with respect to quantum auxiliary
input or side information
so if this input x is entangled with
some y then these properties need to be
preserved
uh even uh when you're uh again even if
you're encoding uh
um even if you're encoding an input x
that
uh has a site information so even given
the site information should be the
coding should be uh
should be correct and simulation should
still hold
um good so um
this is the so the first step to take is
is the is the definition
and now once we have the definition we
try to come up with constructions
and sort of see how they compare to
constructions in
in the classical setting so we're able
to construct
quantum garbled circuits so these are
decomposable quantum randomized
encodings
that work in a gate-by-gate manner and
uh sort of have these
uh depth uh
low depth complexity properties so we
actually have the same construction
and we can instantiate it in two ways
one which gives perfect security so we
can have perfect simulation
uh of the um of the randomized encoding
and the other is computational security
so we rely on computational hardness to
say that
the simulation is indistinguishable from
the original encoding
so well for perfect security we don't
need to make any computational
assumption
and for computational security we just
need a one-way function
that is secure against quantum uh
against uh quantum inverters
um and in the classical setting if we
try to compare the classical garbled
circuits
well this is exactly the same so you can
have a construction perfect security
um without assumptions and uh
okay i got some error message uh you can
still see my screen i hope
um and you can get computational
security using one-way functions
still uh so why use boundary functions
well you're going to get favorable
properties
in terms of complexity so what is the
complexity of computing the encoding
so i said that i'm starting with a
quantum circuit so let's assume that the
circuit has
size s and depth d and let's see what is
the complexity
of computing the encoding of of this of
this circuit
so um in the in in both cases we can
achieve
shallow encoding so the encoding is
going to be in the complexity class
quantum nc 0 with fanout so here it's
actually important
to since well as you saw in the in the
example before
the output is going to be typically much
bigger than the input
and each input bit needs to sort of
affect many outputs so
it's sort of unavoidable even in the
classical setting to avoid fan out
um in the quantum setting fanout is not
as
uh well straightforward as in the
classical setting
and therefore we need to compute in
order to compute our randomizing coding
uh we um can have constant depth
but we do need to use fan-out gates so
this is
where this puts us now let's look at uh
well the size of the encoding so the
depth is going to be constant in this
model
the size well let's start from the
computational setting here we get
sort of the same essentially the same
thing as in the classical setting so
it's just going to be polynomial
in the circuit size that we started from
and in this security parameter
which if you know what is great if not
it doesn't matter
um so this is the same as what happens
in the classical setting
however um in the computational settings
sorry if you if i'm allowing
uh to use quantum monitoring functions
they're kind of secure one way functions
um if i want perfect security well then
we have some
annoying degradation so the size of the
encoding is going to be polynomial in
the size of the circuit
but it's going to be doubly exponential
in the depth and this is in contrast
what happens in the classical setting
where we again get some dependence in
the depth but the dependence is only
exponential and not doubly exponential
and it's a bit curious whether this
whether this sort of worst dependence is
inherent
or whether it's possible to sort of
match the parameters with
uh with the classical setting so this is
uh the complexity of the encoding
uh the decoding is sort of essentially
linear in the size of the encoding so
uh this is also going to be the
complexity of decoding and also the
complexity of simulation
so uh this is what we have in terms of
encoding so we might have some blow up
which in the computational setting is
only polynomial in the size
but we have sort of shrunk the depth by
quite a bit
another useful property is well remember
that we talked about decomposability
so each input bit is encoded by itself
so if i'm if i
own one one input bit or qubit then i
only need to look at this uh
sort of random tape and entanglement
tape in order to
compute the part of the encoding that
depends on my input
now what if my what if my input bit is
classical isn't it a bit unfair to ask
me to look at this
uh sort of uh quantum quantum entangled
state in order to
generate my encoding well our our
encoding scheme is fair
in the sense that if you're a classical
uh if your bit is classical
then uh you only need to look at
classical randomness in order to encode
uh in order to encode
the in order to compute the part of the
encoding that depends on your bit so
there's still going to be some part of
encoding that's quantum
it's actually an interesting open
problem to uh
to show an encoding which is completely
classical
uh and uh uh well there's also some
possibility results for this
um so there's going to be some quantum
parts for the encoding but
the part that depends on the classical
input is going to only be classical
um so this is a useful uh potentially
useful property
so this is one construction that we show
uh in the in the paper
uh and uh well it at least uh uh morally
matches
uh what is known in the classical ward
so we're fairly satisfied except for
this double exponential
uh double exponential dependence um
we also have another construction in the
paper um which
i guess is worse in the sense that it
doesn't have this shallow encoding it
doesn't
uh sort of the trade-off between uh um
uh complexity is is uh not not the same
as in
this construction that i showed but the
overall structure is simpler
um and you do get some beneficial
properties from uh
from from this uh from this construction
as uh was sort of shown in the follow-up
work that used this in the context of
secure
multi-party computation in the quantum
setting um
so this is another thing that we show in
the paper uh we also show an application
in the context of zero knowledge so zero
knowledge proofs for qma
are uh sort of uh uh very uh
uh sort of highlighted right now and
there was this very nice work of
uh broadband and grillo that presented
the first
um zero knowledge protocol for q for qma
which takes the form of a sigma protocol
so if you don't know what it is don't
worry about it i'm not going to talk
about this application
after i'm done with this uh with this
line um
so uh essentially a sigma protocol is a
three message protocol
where uh the verifier messages is just
uh random points
and broadband gorilla were the first to
show that this is possible for qma and
it is with a
sort of a very nice and complicated uh
reduction
uh of of a qma hardness of some uh of
some problem
and what we show is sort of a fairly
simple way to achieve
uh the uh to achieve this uh sigma
protocol a sigma protocol
with which with with some favorable
properties
and we do this essentially by taking a
classical construction and replacing the
classical garbled circuit with a quantum
garbled circuit
and this is more or less what you need
to do so if we think that this exam
exemplifies the usefulness of this
uh of this notion in converting things
from the classical to the quantum
setting
uh for the rest of this talk i'm going
to sort of give you a high
a brief overview of this alternative
construction so we want to try to
construct um
a randomized randomized encoding with
some favorable favorable properties that
we're going to see
for general quantum circuits so
um let me be a little more concrete
about what is our task
so we want to show this question uh
there's a question in the audience
yeah if you go back to the previous
slide um i actually just had a basic
question
so at the top when you define the
correctness property for instance
are you considering like f which
is a quantum circuit that has a
deterministic output or do you need that
definition to like
be about the distribution of outputs
right so the definition is inherently
distribution
distributional because well you f can
perform measurements and it can
well it can even uh sort of uh take
take on cila registers and do hadamard
and measure those things so it can
definitely generate randomness as well
so uh this this definition talks about
distributions so i'm taking a sample
from the distribution fx uh the
simulation okay so the correctness
obviously
uh just takes x and computes um
and computes uh uh it takes a sample
from f hat
and computes a sample from f and the
simulation uh sort of does the same uh
the same thing sort of in reverse um
samples from the correct distribution
gives you a sample from the correct
distribution
is that does that answer the question
yeah it's true that i mean in this sense
this is one of the uh
aspects in which the quantum definition
requires more care
than the classical than the classical
definition because the classical
definition you can always say
well if my function is randomized and
just fix the random string and then
um you know just go on as if it was
deterministic whereas here you can't uh
play these tricks
all right um so let me go on um
and and talk about the construction well
unless i guess the definition
and uh well maybe the same the results
is kind of important so if there's other
questions and i'm happy to take them now
before we dive in you can write them in
the q a also and we'll take them later
um okay so i want to construct i want to
construct a simple
um a simple uh randomize encoding
for any quantum circuit so for any
quantum circuit queue
i want to compute an encoding that looks
that has the following form
so i'm going to take my input i'm
perhaps adding some auxiliary register
and then i'm just applying a random
clifford on it um
and this is going to be the quantum part
of my encoding in addition i'm going to
compute some classical site information
uh that could depend on well the quantum
circuit that i
started from and also the randomness
that i use to generate a random clifford
but this is
just going to be some classical
information that i'm writing down so
you know hopefully this is simple enough
for you so all i need to do is take my
input
apply a random clifford on it this
random clifford has nothing to do with
my quantum circuit
and then i need to sort of write down
some calculations
and compute some classical side
information so this is what we want to
do
and what i want to uh what i want to do
what i want to do here is show sort of a
sequence
of um a sequence of encodings
so i'm going to use the sort of
composability property so i'm going to
start with a general circuit
and then i'm going to encode it by a
different circuit code by different
circuit different circuits so on
until we get to the point where we get a
circuit that has this form
so notice that this is the encoding this
is the encoding function
this means that the output of f hat so
if i'm applying f hat
then all i'm getting is this quantum
state
that is the output here and this
classical information this is all i need
to give you in order for you to be able
to decode
the output of q so i'm going to start
with a warm-up so general quantum
circuits is hard i'm just going to start
with a clifford
um so i want my the circuit that i want
to encode now
is some clifford uh some clifford g so
it takes x and output
g applied on x uh and let's see how we
encode it
so um we want to have this sort of
random clifford that's going to
be applied on the input so i'm just
going to generate a random clifford and
apply it on my input
and you know let's take that as a
starting point and see what we need to
do in order to decode after the fact
so um i i'm just going to mention uh
probably
most of you know uh that um for clifford
flippers are
very convenient in the sense that we can
efficiently sample a random clifford
and there also exists a canonical
representation so if i'm giving you a
clifford circuit
you can come up with a canonical that's
just all cliffords that compute the same
function
are going to have the same canonical
representation and this is going to be
important for us
so we're going to apply random clifford
so we start with x and we're going to
get rx
now i'm going to give you classical side
information that will allow you
to recover the original gx and this i'm
going to do just by computing
g times r inverse which is also a
clifford
um and i'm going to give you the
canonical representation
this i mean it's a classical description
of the canonical representation
of the circuit g times our inverse i'm
going to call this s
um and this is going to be um this is
going to be our encoding i mean this
this is just uh
um um the has the form that we want
now why does it work for decoding well
if i'm giving you the output
uh i'm giving you the output of f hat so
this is rx and
s i'm just going to multiply s i'm just
going to apply i guess the circuit
s on the quantum part of the encoding
and i'm going to get gx which is what i
wanted
now if i want to simulate i want to show
you that i didn't give you any
additional information
well um this is this is fairly this is
again easy to do now i'm just going to
so what do i do when i want to simulate
i'm starting with the output i'm
starting with gx
and i want to simulate the output of the
the output of the encoding so i want to
simulate something that looks like
looks like rx and an s that looks like
this
so i'm just going to do things in the
reverse order i'm going to take s to be
a random clifford
and notice that the marginal of s is
just the same as the marginal of a
random clifford
so i'm going to take s to be my uh to be
a random clifford
and instead of r times x i'm going to
give you s inverse
times the input y that i received and
this
is distributed in the exact same way as
the original
um as the original encoding so this is
perfect simulation this is
this gives you perfect privacy and
notice that in order to perform this
process the simulation
i didn't need to know what the original
g was and this is actually important if
you if you're allowed to know g then
encoding is trivial
um so um notice that in order to
um in order to perform the simulation uh
i just
generated a random s and multiplied it
by y i didn't care if y
came from g1 or g2 or some other you
know whatever
uh clifford that you start from so this
is sort of a toy example of the simplest
thing that you can do
and this is a little bit takes after uh
some notions in classical uh randomized
coding
um okay so this is a warm up cliffords
are well
are an easy case uh so um
[Music]
what i'm going to do now uh is talk
about well is the
i for some reason i thought i'm i need
to end in three minutes but that's not
true right i have like 18 minutes
um good so uh well i hope that was clear
so
that was just ladies and gentlemen but
just to answer that we wanted to save a
little question
and answer time that's all uh yeah uh
yeah i'm happy to save everybody the the
time but uh but yeah i'm hoping but but
well we have time so
if you do have questions then please do
ask or write down write it down for
yourselves and
we'll come back to this in a minute good
so um
now we want to generalize we want to go
beyond uh beyond clifford's
and what i'm going to look at is this
class of clifford plus
plus measurement what is this class so
this is a class of circuits
that is defined by two cliffords g0 and
g1
it takes n plus one qubits uh x and b
and the first thing that it does is
measures the qubit b
uh gets a classical bit and then applies
well g sub b so control on this
classical bit
it either applies g zero or applies g
one so this is well a little bit more
than uh
than just doing a clifford but um
we know that if you can actually encode
this function class and you can encode
everything
and this is because you can apply the um
sort of magic state transformation
uh of braving kitev and um
and and represent any quantum circuit um
using this form so they're using layers
where each layer looks like this
and uh we can actually send again using
the composability property of randomized
encoding
we can encode each layer at a time and
and get the
form that we want so really um so the
task reduces to the task
of um giving an encoding for this
clifford plus measurement function class
and again i want the encoding to have
this form
so i'm taking my input possibly adding
some ancilla applying a random clifford
and this is going to be the quantum part
of your input of your output sorry
so you're going to get this sort of
quantum value in addition you're going
to get some classical side information
and from that you need to be able to
recover the output of this
original of this original circuit so
let's see how we do this
um so again we're going to we're going
to do it step by step i guess in the
previous slide we only had one step but
here we're going to have a few
um so remember that well we're going to
try to use the similarity of this class
to the class of cliffords
so before we just had one clifford here
we have two clifford g0 and g1
but actually notice that regardless of
the clifford that we apply
in the previous slide we did the same
thing on x we just applied a random
clifford on it
regardless of what g was so let's do
that let's just take
x apply random clifford on it and now
let's think what we need to do
in order to recover uh the value that we
wanted so
if i just wanted to encode g0 or just g1
then i had to give you
the classical the classical information
g0 times our inverse or g1 times our
inverse
and this would allow you to sort of
recover the output value
so what i'm what i'm doing here i'm
going to take the qubit b
i'm going to measure it and then uh
again control of the output of the
measurement
i'm going to give you one of two
classical strings either the string g0
times our inverse or
the string g1 times our inverse and
um again from the for the same reasons
as we had in the
warm-up before um if i'm giving you the
output
of this function so one of these two
classical strings
and as well as the output of this like r
times x
then you should be able to recover um
the the
proper output which is sort of g times b
applied
to uh applied to the input x so
right now i sort of just use the the
warm-up as a building block in my
construction
so this is kind of cool because well we
we took the com the complex part of this
construction so you'd think that the
part has to do with the clifford is
going to be complex and we sort of took
care of
that and now this is already in the form
that we need and we only need to take
care
of this uh sort of first part so we're
going to try to see how to encode
this value so let's see how to do this
so i'm going to sort of zoom in on it
and
this is the uh the circuit that we want
to that we want to encode
and um well this seems sort of
like maybe like a harder task well i
said before that the clifford was hard
but now looking at this obviously this
is the hard part
because i need to encode a measurement
which is not even a unitary and i want
to encode it using well a random
clifford and some classical side
information
which again at least at first glance
seems like a harder task
so let's see how to do this um
so the first thing i'm going to do is
i'm going to sort of run this sort of
multiplexer coherently so first of all
i'm going to sort of
use c naught in order to take b comma 0
and compute from this
b comma g b r inverse
and then i'm going to perform the
measurement on all of the on the
respective outputs
and this is well an identical
functionality so obviously this
circuit encodes the previous circuit and
well now well this thing is a clifford
so this is good
but now i'm sort of left with exactly
the hard part which is doing the
measurement
but turns out this is actually not the
hard part and and certain quantum
literature we know how to handle this
uh and and this is known as the the z
twirl so
uh in fact you can replace um a
measurement in the computational basis
by just applying z to the r for a random
r
um and again this is sort of well known
that this captures
the this captures the functionality of
the measurement process
but i think this is also something
that's insightful in this notion of
quantum randomizing coding
because once we have this notion i can
just say to you
that um you know a random z twirl is
just a randomizing coding
of the measurement uh um you know of the
measurement operation
and this would tell you what is what the
properties of the z turtle are
so i mean once we have this notion we
have like a good terminology to sort of
address
what it means for like this circuit
actually captures the essence of the
other circuit and so on
um so this is sort of a well-known
well-known
solution to the problem and indeed this
allows us to
uh encode this uh this function uh
using uh using a clifford a clifford
circuit a random or rather
using well um a clifford that is sampled
from
some uh distribution which is defined by
the randomness of the
sample from some distribution which is
defined by this uh randomness r
and well i guess a lot of other things
that are called r from this slide um
okay so um we have uh um we have an
encoding in the form of clifford
uh let's just plug that back in here
and now we see that we have the form
that we wanted right
now if you look at the circuit uh you
take the input and you apply some
clifford on it it's not a random
clifford because it's like
random here and some weird distribution
here
um but i know how to handle cliffords
i'm just going to do the
uh this group randomizer that i uh that
i mentioned before
and i'm going to get uh i'm going to get
to the form
that i wanted uh so i'm now i just need
to apply random clip
on everything and here well i'm going to
get some classical side information
but depends on everything on g0 or g1
all the randomness values that i used
and importantly i use the fact that this
group randomizer
actually hides the circuit that i used
because i i don't want to
need to leak these randomness values
otherwise well these encodings are not
going to be
uh are not going to be private
so uh so this is essentially how the how
the encoding works
so i i took this well you can i don't
know how complicated it looks to you but
somewhat complicated
quantum circuit and convert it into this
well i claim arguably simple uh form so
it's just a random clifford
and then some classical computation this
classical computation can be pretty
complicated like who wants to now
compute these uh this product and then
the canonical representation so on and
so forth
luckily um since it's all classical
computation we can just use classical
randomizing coding
and simplify that part away so i mean
don't worry about the complexity
of the classical parts we can always
just use classical randomized encoding
in order to make it shallow and nice and
have and have good properties
so um so so i'm arguing that even the
classical part is not too bad
uh in this uh in this construction
so this is essentially it this is sort
of the simpler construction uh in our
paper
um and let me wrap up
by sort of talking a little bit more in
high level what would you hope to do
with with quantum randomizing coatings
um so i guess you can
uh you can think about first importing
classical application
applications from the classical world to
the quantum world for example
a quantum multi-party computation uh
this is something that's already
done and it's fairly sort of
straightforward uh idea to think about
and the other thing which i think could
be more interesting interesting is to
think about
maybe there's maybe there's quantum
applications so i don't know
uh i guess in chin may talk cinemates
talk we heard about
uh sometimes it's important to consider
quantum circuits that are shallow
so if you have a transformation that can
transform arbitrary circuits into
shallow circuits i don't know is this
something that can be useful somewhere
the notion of shallowness is not exactly
the same as as uh
in chi mei's talk but just just as sort
of
a conceptual idea i don't know in if
there are other places where
uh these things are important in the
classical world it turned out to be
um fairly fairly significant and useful
uh
so i guess this is this bullet is like
uh i think would be the more interesting
one
to try to pick up um yeah so in the
classical so
as i said the first the most
straightforward thing is to work for
secure multi-party computation
i guess i didn't say what secure
multi-party computation is well this is
the application where multiple parties
each one has their own input and they
want to compute a function
on the collection of their inputs um and
as i said the
quantum as i said well randomized
encodings are useful here
and hopefully well evidently uh
it was used already in follow-up works
in order to achieve low round complexity
uh for multi-party computation in the
quantum setting
uh i mentioned this psm uh so let me say
what it is i i
sort of mentioned it in the beginning
when i talked about the motivation
so let me sort of uh uh in the few
minutes that i have left
uh tell you a little bit about psm which
is private simultaneous messages
and the quantum sort of version of this
problem
which is sort of addressed by quantum
randomizing coding
so uh as so if you remember the
beginning of the talk i was sort of
imagining
a quantum state that has two parts um
and we have two parties one party has
the first part x and the other party has
the other part y uh these can be
arbitrarily entangled of course
and these are non-communicating parties
they possibly share epr pairs or
shared randomness um and
these parties want to sort of produce
messages m1 and m2 which could be
quantum
which will allow um a third party to
compute
a function on both of their inputs uh
and this needs to be done privately in
the sense that
uh uh this computation does not reveal
to this third party
anything about the input x and y other
than the output
and furthermore you can require and you
can also get um
that you don't even get information on
what is the function that they computed
so the um this receiver
actually manages to compute f of x y but
doesn't know what
x was what y was or what f was um
and again the classical version of this
uh um
of this problem is sort of foundational
when talking about secure multi-party
computation you can think about this
sort of first
toy example um and in the quantum
setting
uh i didn't know how to i wouldn't know
how to solve it um
uh if not by using uh by using uh
quantum randomizing coding
so i don't know if first of all i think
it's interesting by itself that you can
do this
um maybe there's other ways i mean i
wouldn't be surprised if there's some
sort of
uh uh high complexity so the point in
randomizing
well the randomizing codings that we
talk about is to also have
some efficiency uh efficiency guarantees
so for example
like the length of these messages are
going to be like the length of the
randomizing coding so we can have some
bound on them
but um i i don't know if there's some
trivial solution
uh that uses arbitrarily long messages
uh
and and achieves this functionality uh i
think uh i mean i'd be interested to
know
um but but i wouldn't be surprised and
again sort of um
studying this problem from uh
with again with the goal of uh trying to
sort of optimize for different
complexity measures
turns out to be useful uh in in in
various settings
uh except well i think also from first
principles it's pretty interesting to
think about
um yeah so the last thing i wanted to
talk about was these notions of
functional encryption
and program obfuscation which are now uh
sort of
uh uh take center stage in in classical
cryptography also a little bit in
quantum cryptography
uh literature uh these are sort of more
advanced cryptographic notions
i don't want to get into details uh but
for those of you who know well we know
that there is a connection between
randomized encodings functional
encryption obfuscation
essentially well functional encryption
notification you can think about them as
notions of randomizing codings
that also have compression of
information in one way or another at
least this is
one way to think about it now if i had a
quantum randomize encoding
such that i could encode a quantum
circuit with classical input
using a classical encoding then i could
sort of push away the problem of sort of
doing the compression part
to classical functional encryption
obfuscation so if we had
um so if we could if we could have um
uh quantum garbled circuits or quantum
randomize encodings where the encoding
is classical
like the encoding is completely
classical so if the input is classical
and i'm giving you a classical
description of the circuit then the
encoding that you get is completely
classical
um then you'd get some uh very
interesting consequences
uh when you combine it with with
classical cryptography uh
classical cryptographic objects um we
know there are some um
uh obstacles and uh uh and
impossibilities so you need to be very
careful
with what definition of randomized
encoding uh you're using
um but again this is sort of very
interesting uh uh to understand what can
and cannot be achieved and if it can be
achieved what are the consequences
and well i'm hoping guessing that
there's going to be more
thank you
[Applause]
thank you for questions
i actually have a uh speaker i have a
question uh
so so in in this on the quantum side
it's these magic states that play the
role to lift
these cliffords to the general
circuit so these parity encodings what
happens on the classical side how do you
go from
is there something similar or is that is
that more difficult to do on the
on that so you're saying what's the
counterpart of the magic states in the
classical setting
yeah so somehow in the classical setting
you well the problem sort of reduces to
just the classical part of like it's
just like computing the classical part
of the encoding
so the part about the magic state part
doesn't
directly come up or um i guess you're
saying what happens when you apply
this to a classical i'm taking a
classical circuit i'm going to represent
it using like t gates or toefl
and so on what is the what is the
quantum randomizing coding going to look
like
no sorry sorry i i was sort of trying to
drawing an analogy you know so
so clifford's maybe they correspond to
parities and
you know so they are the simple part but
and then here you lift it using
magic states but on the on the classical
side when you're going beyond parodies
you've got to do something so
does that look more complicated there or
is there is there some simple gadget
that
then gets you from parity to everything
i mean the
i i think so there's also the
measurement i mean not just the t gates
right i mean we need to work in order to
encode the
the measurement this is this is what
makes it difficult it's not just
clifford
um so
you're asking if there's a counterpart
in the classical setting um
i don't have a direct sort of yeah
it seems like the difficulty in the
classical setting comes up in a sort of
different way which is sort of
more similar to how we have the our
first construction in the paper which is
not what uh what i described in the talk
um so here i guess uh um
it's a little more subtle to see the
sort of classical the classical analog i
think again so
what's going to happen is that this
magic stage transformation is just going
to push all the classical
uh computation into what i call the
classical part of encoding so you're
actually going to need to handle it
when you're sort of computing the
classical part of the encoding
it's really nice
following up on lumesha's question uh
what is done for nands
and other complex functions beyond xor
right so i mean yeah so in the classical
world i didn't say i left you i left you
a little bit in the dark
so um
i don't have that many slides it's gonna
be okay to
cast to go backwards yeah so in uh so
as you notice here so for each one of
these uh so each for each wire
i generate the random bit so if you're
looking at nands you're going to
generate something that is longer so
each wire is going to have like a bunch
of keys
that correspond to what happens when
this wire is zero and what happens when
this wire is one
and sort of similarly to this gadget but
sort of much more complicated
is going to be a gadget that is sort of
going to translate if you got some value
uh you know some some one of these if if
the value that you get on the wire
uh is is something then you need to be
able to obtain
sort of the value of the corresponds to
the end and this is done essentially by
giving you
all the sort of different so in the
classical world it's sort of easy
if you can just think about the truth
table and encode the truth table of the
of the gate so if the truth table has uh
in this case
in this in the case of of uh two input
gates
uh it's just going to have sort of four
lines then for each one of these lines
you're going to have a translation
that takes um uh that takes sort of the
encoding
of the input the the incoming wires and
translates them into an encoding of the
outgoing wire
which is exactly what happens here so if
you look at for example this gate
then if you look at uh this r1 plus r2
plus r5
then this allows you to take uh this
sort of
x1 plus r1 x2 plus r2 and obtain
the correct output which is x1 plus x2
but now randomized by r5
so you need to do the same thing but for
for nand gate which
is uh uh slightly more complicated but
still you want to sort of preserve this
uh invariant where um you know if i'm
starting from
uh if i if i took the randomized version
uh
of the value on this wire on the two
input wires and i
uh sort of uh um combine them in the
right way then i obtain
uh the encoded version of the output
thank you we have one q a and maybe this
will be the last question
um from vietnam uh zigfa can you say
more about the money my 20 barrier
um yeah so um
so yeah more my uh actually showed a
barrier
towards getting uh classic let me maybe
go to definition
um towards getting a classical encoding
um like i said before so uh you you'd
assume
you'd hope that um maybe it's possible
if my
circuit is has a classical description
and my input is classical
then maybe my encoding can also be
classical however
uh so long as the output of the circuit
can be can be a quantum state
uh the ability to simulate actually
um could violate clonability so notice
that i mean
f of x is a quantum state so it should
be unclonable
and here i'm saying that i can simulate
it
using a classical value so if i have a
classical encoding then i should be able
to simulate this quantum value
using a classical value now classical
values can be cloned
so what i can do or what more my does
is say that they could uh
you know use the simulator get a
classical description of this quantum
state that i started from
clone it because it's just classical and
then apply the decoding procedure and
the coding procedures
should still work because well this
sample is sampled from the correct
distribution
or from something that is close to the
correct distribution and therefore
what you obtain in the end is uh cloning
of your
uh of this uh sort of state that you
started from and this can be quantum
state even if your circuit is classical
and your input is classical
and therefore this gives you a barrier
uh um towards uh sort of getting some
notions at least
getting simulation notions of simulation
uh
in the uh completely classical setting
so this is
uh um at least one of the results in the
paper
the one that's relevant to what i was
saying did not say is thanks and i would
like to join him in also saying thanks
to you
zvitka thank you very much for a nice
talk and let's give
it a hand
all right thank you so i think this
concludes the session for today
uh yeah just a quick word like so uh
i just wanted to say that um officially